bonjour à tous et à tous heureux de vous
retrouver frais engagés et passionnés
pour la journée qui va s'ouvrir merci
aux jeunes républicains au bureau des
jeunes républicains pour leur travail et
leurs idées une jeunesse qui n'a pas
d'idées c'est une jeunesse qui disparaît
et à l'évidence vous n'êtes pas prêts
nous ne sommes pas prêts nous la droite
républicaine de disparaître avec les
convictions qui sont les nôtres
désormais nous allons lancer la première
table ronde re plénière qui va s'ouvrir
dans quelques minutes et j'appelle à à
sur cette scène gilles platret vice
président des républicains et maire de
chalon sur saône ludovic permet
vice-président de la région sud est
secrétaire général adjoint des
républicains était au michel qui vont
nous rejoindre pour animer cette table
ronde à leurs côtés et autour du thème
protéger libérer rassemblé quelles
priorités c'est charles consignes et
écrivains et avocats qui contribuera
jean pierre blanc directeur général des
cafés malongo et rachida dati pour qui
je vous demande un tonnerre
d'applaudissements
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci de votre enthousiasme
on est très heureux de vous recevoir et
surtout de commencer cette journée sur
l'élan qui a été donnée hier par ce
rassemblement
disait un certain nombre d'entre vous
que et christian je pense me contredira
pas qu'il faut remonter quand même à
quelques années pour voir rassemblement
de jeunes aussi massif dans notre
famille politique vous l'avez fait c'est
grâce à vous et ça ce sera loin de ses
frontières
[Applaudissements]
christian jacob a décidé de vous offrir
un livre de chevet pour tout l'automne
et le printemps c'est les propositions
que nous avons travaillé ces derniers
temps vous les connaissez vous ont été
exprimées depuis hier elles sont à la
fois la ligne d'un héritage est
également d'un constat et d'une ambition
d'un héritage parce que lorsque vous
tournez les pages de ce livre est que
j'ai entre les mains et que vous avez
aussi
c'est une longue histoire qui nous amène
jusqu ici cette histoire c'est d'abord
celle d'une volonté celle du général de
gaulle de ne pas laisser la france dans
la main du déclin et je pense que cet
héritage nous l'avons fait vivre dans
ces mois de travail de long travail que
nous avons mené au siège beaucoup
évidemment à distance dans ses temps
épidémique mais qui nous ont permis je
le pense très sincèrement de rester
fidèle à ce que la droite républicaine a
toujours défendu c'est a dit c'est à
dire mettre au dessus de toutes les
considérations l'intérêt primordial de
la france nous avons la france au coeur
il ce programme présidentiel
c'est d'abord la france qui en est le
coeur c'est d'abord la france qui en
constitue la préoccupation principale
n'oublions jamais que dans tous les
débats que nous pouvons avoir dans tous
les conflits parfois et le jeu des
ambitions tout ça n'a de sens que si ça
revient sur l'ambition fondamentale nous
sommes résolument le parti de la france
et des français mes amis ne l'oublions
jamais et combattons pour ça
alors
pour essayer de recréer un peu dans le
détail de ces mesures et surtout pour
rester dans les trois axes que nous
avons tracée nous avons fait un travail
préalable qui est un travail de constats
fidèle à l'héritage qui est le nôtre
nous sommes atterrés de ce que la france
est en train de devenir sourds les coups
de boutoir de deux quinquennats
misérable celui de monsieur hollande
prolongé par celui de monsieur macron
nous sommes atterrés de voir que ce pays
que nous aimons par dessus tout est en
train d'emprunter une voie terrible
celle du déclassement nous sommes
atterrés nous qui avons toujours plaidé
pour l'unité de la nation
de voir que jamais la france n'a été
autant divisée et jamais le pouvoir n'a
donné le signe qu'il n'aimait pas les
français
or nous avons dans notre coeur cet amour
des français de la france et c'est
pourquoi ce programme est empreint de
cette préoccupation première
protéger quand on aime on protège
quand on sait que les nôtres sont
fébriles mise en danger perturbés dans
leur vie quotidienne alors l'idée de
protection devient première et c'est
bien ce qui constitue cette première
phase du programme libéré car
aujourd'hui l'état a pris une emprise
sur nos vies absolument apocalyptique or
je vous rappelle que nous sommes le
parti de la liberté nous l'avons
toujours défendu dans les moments
terribles de notre histoire comme dans
des moments plus ou moins agitée nous
avons toujours fait confiance à l'homme
si nous sommes héritiers du libéralisme
c'est d'abord parce que nous pensons que
ce n'est pas à l'état de dicter nos vies
c'est à l'ensemble des citoyens de
dicter à l'état ce qu'il doit être c'est
pour ça que le deuxième thème c'est
celui de la liberté et enfin parce que
nous sommes gaulliste le rassemblement
fait partie de ce que nous voulons
défendre il n'y a pas de pays qui se
projette vers l'avenir pas de pays qui
est une lumière pour le monde pas de
pays qui rayonne comme la france l'a
fait dans les siècles passés il n'y a
pas le rassemblement de son peuple voilà
l'enjeu voilà ce sur quoi nous avons
bâti ce projet mon cher christian nous
te le devons tu n'est certes pas le seul
à avoir travaillé mais celui qui a donné
l'impulsion nécessaire c'est toi je veux
que personne ne l'oublient parce que ce
travail de fond c'est le travail
préalable à la reconquête bien sûr que
le temps du choix des personnes viendra
mais s'il n'y a que les personnes c'est
une aventure sans lendemain nous sommes
le parti de la france nous avons écrit
un programme pour la france est
aujourd'hui avec nos invités que nous
allons bientôt vous présentez nous
allons le porter le discuter et demain
le faire vaincre merci à vous
merci merci gilles c'est vrai ça fait
maintenant près de dix ans que notre
pays est gouverné par une gauche qui n'a
finalement pour seule ambition que de
punir que de comprendre est que de
diviser aujourd'hui avec christian jacob
avec aurélien pradié avec l'ensemble des
républicains nous démontrons qu'une
autre voie est possible
cette voix c'est celle des territoires
c'est celle qui vise à protéger les
français en restaurant l'autorité de
l'état tu l'as dit gilles c'est celle
qui vise également à libérer les
énergies à libérer les entreprises qui
sont aujourd'hui droit effectuée par
trop de taxes par trop de normes et par
trop de champ social c'est celle qui
vise aussi sherjill tu l'as dit a
rassemblé à rassembler les françaises et
les français autour d'un nouveau projet
de société autour du travail autour du
mérite autour de l'effort et de la
récompense est ensemble c'est parce que
nous sommes unis c'est parce que nous
sommes de droite et que nous n'avons pas
peur de dire que nous sommes de droite
et nous n'avons pas l'intention de nous
en excuser et que nous sommes le seul
parti de france à pouvoir rassembler
aujourd'hui autant de générer issia pour
paris et qui si nous sommes unis et
c'est parce que nous sommes unis que
nous allons gagner la présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
et pour commencer et pour commencer
cette plénière et sa grosse conquête
avec notre président christian jacob
avec tous les républicains
avec la chute à tati
nous avions accueillir un jeune avocat
il est brillant il est secrétaire de la
conférence du barreau de paris il
enflamme les plateaux de télévision il
en plus aux flammes les radios c'est
charles concis dit un grand tonnerre
d'applaudissements
[Musique]
il arrive dans cinq minutes
également
présenté
un homme
qui est né
dans notre région provence alpes côte
d'azur
[Applaudissements]
et qui je crois aussi beaucoup d'autres
qualités parce qu'il possède cette
qualité qu'il est un spécialiste de la
grande distribution français sur le
marché du café il est l'initiateur du
commerce équitable dans la grande
distribution et monsieur vous êtes tout
de même le directeur général des grands
cafés bars lingots donc un grand merci à
jean pierre blanc qui nous fait
l'honneur aujourd'hui de sa présence
à mon tour évidemment avec beaucoup
d'émotion tant qu'élu parisien dans le
17ème avec geoffroy boulard le maire du
xvième j'ai beaucoup d'émotion
évidemment en étant sur cette scène
parce que geoffrey et est devant moi et
je peux vous dire que je ne serais pas
là sans lui donc je voudrais qu'on
l'applaudisse parce que vraiment il est
exceptionnel
j'ai évidemment l'honneur de vous
présenter une ancienne garde des sceaux
ancien député européen maire du 7e
arrondissement et président du groupe
changer paris au conseil de paris je
vous demande de faire un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour rachida dati
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puisque rachida viennent à être aussi
brillamment présenté je voudrais pour
lancer notre débat lui posez peut-être
la première question on a on a beaucoup
travaillé nous avons identifié une
trentaine de thèmes prioritaires pour la
france de demain dans le cadre de cette
reconquête que nous devons français et
au pays devrait savoir selon toi rachida
qu'elle est aujourd'hui à tes yeux la
priorité numéro un après pratiquement
cinq années de présidence macron qu'elle
est aujourd'hui ce qui nécessite le
maximum d'efforts le maximum de
concentration demain si nous arrivons au
pouvoir et nous allons y arriver
merci j merci théo pour dans cette table
ronde d'abord moi je voulais remercier
l'ensemble des jeunes républicains et
des moins jeunes que nous sommes pour
leur présence aujourd'hui pour le succès
de ces deux journées faut quand même le
rappeler je voulais remercier l'ensemble
non seulement de l'ensemble des élus qui
sont aujourd'hui présents
guillem qu alain carayon qui
effectivement a pu organiser avec succès
ces deux journées je voulais rentrer
remercier c'est vrai tout à l'heure tu
es au tueur mercier geoffroy boulard
tu le dit gilles pour la reconquête et
nous sommes dans la reconquête je pense
qu'il ya une attente forte des français
de la droite et du centre parce que moi
je considère que la france n'a jamais
été autant à droite
qu'en ce moment j'ai toujours considéré
que la france était majoritairement à
droite est de plus en plus elle nous
donne des moules ans des signaux forts
pour que nous répondions à leurs
attentes et leurs préoccupations et les
français ont compris que nous pouvions
et répandre comment ils l'ont compris je
parle évidemment sur le contrôle de
l'ensemble des maires parisiens qui sont
ici pardon pas pour être parisien mais
avec agnès evren quand on a commencé la
campagne presse parisienne personne n'y
croyait tellement personne n'y croyait
que personne voulait être sur nos listes
ça nous a permis d'ailleurs de
renouveler l'ensemble du groupe des élus
parisiens on à renouveler les
générations
on a renouvelé les profits on a
renouvelé on a recruté des des talents
et des talents qui se battent pour les
parisiens qui se battent pour les
français pour les citoyens et donc c'est
pour ça que je voulais faire ce petit
mot particulier agnès passe quand on a
commencé on était que toutes les deux et
personne ne croyait vraiment en nous
mais on a eu le soutien je dois le dire
de christian jacob et avant lui
[Applaudissements]
et je dois dire aussi de laurent
wauquiez qui était président américain
parce que des erreurs nous en faisons
tous mais apprendre de ses erreurs c'est
beaucoup mieux et en tous les cas il ya
une chose moi qui m'anime c'est le refus
de la division parce que depuis 2007 on
a fait une présidentielle triomphal et
triomphante en 2007 et depuis les haines
les frondes les divisions nous emmener
et nous avions un objectif
en tous les cas à paris avec christian
jacob quand il a pris effectivement la
succession de le révoquer y compris ce
qu'ils avaient amorcé leur en vo ket
l'union l'union l'union et le
rassemblement
et moi je remercie les élus l'ensemble
des élus de nos groupes mais aussi de
groupes de damien abad à l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi le groupe de
françois retailleau au sénat nous
n'avons jamais été aussi unis
qu'en ce moment et ça on le doit c'est
vrai merci christian d'avoir permis cela
[Musique]
et donc que nous dit que nous ont
démontré les expériences récentes les
élections municipales départementales
régionales
à chaque fois la déjouer les sondages et
on a déjoué j'allais dire les sondages
pas malgré nous pas à l'insu de notre
plein gré c'est parce qu'on a travaillé
un projet parce qu'on a des propositions
et des propositions qui sont crédibles
qui sont réalisables qui sont efficaces
parce que nous avons l'expérience parce
que nous avons la connaissance parce que
nous avons les élus de terrain et c'est
vrai que si nous n'avions pas cette
expérience cette compétence ses talents
cette union je pense que les français
nous aurait tourné le dos pour les
municipales et départementales et
régionales donc ce que l'appel que nous
faisons aujourd'hui tu as raison gilles
de rapper pardon on déborde un peu tu
arrêtes tu a raison de rappeler le choix
du candidat ça viendra en son temps moi
ce que je souhaite c'est que nous
puissions continuer à creuser ce sillon
du projet des idées de ce rassemblement
et nous sommes déterminés aurélien
pradié que je vois plus qu'ils étaient
là dans à l'instant moi c'est vrai que
ce sont des nouveaux élus ces élus comme
aurélien pradié avec les dents ils sont
allés chercher leur élection et donc et
c'est pour ça et dans une des régions
totalement improbable c'est comme ça que
nous devons continuer et la
présidentielle je vois pas comment on ne
peut pas être élue je vois pas comment
les français peuvent nous tourner le dos
s'ils peuvent nous tourner le dos
6ème division si on se rassemble pas et
si on n'a pas un candidat unique pour la
présidentielle
et ça c'est un devoir pour nous mais
c'est aussi un devoir et une
responsabilité pour les candidats qui se
présentent moi je le dis comme vous le
savez tous c'est ma conviction
personnelle je ne suis pas favorable à
la primaire mais je souhaite un candidat
je veux un candidat gagne on va gagner
nous allons gagner nous devons gagner
nous devons gagner fait la france nous
devons gagner évidemment pour les
français et je ne vois pas comment on ne
peut pas gagner avec le projet avec les
dirigeants que nous avons mais aussi
avec la réalité c'est quoi la france
aujourd'hui un pays fracturé un pays où
la délinquance n'a jamais autant explosé
avec eux une liberté économique et vous
serez plus à même d'en parler monsieur
blanc sur cette liberté contrainte
aujourd'hui on est sur une clé une
économie totalement administrées on
n'est pas du tout sûr liberté économique
donc nous on est le parti de la liberté
on est le parti de la sécurité ont ni le
parti de l'autorité parce que moi je
veux bien qu'on dise tout ce qu'on veut
l'autorité doit se rétablir partout dans
tous les territoires français et pas que
dans certains quartiers partout en
france et en premier au premier chef à
paris on le voit et c'est on n'est pas
dans des territoires éloignés nous
sommes pour le rétablissement de la
sécurité
nous sommes pour une justice efficace
justice efficace effective des sanctions
pénales quand elles sont prononcés
qu'elles soient exécutés parce que on
peut parler je pense qu'il y aura des
questions et c'est pour ça que
aulas déjà vifs débats avec charles
conseiller c'est que la certitude de la
sanction moi je pense que c'est plus
important que d'augmenter les quantum de
peine qui ne sont jamais ni ni
appliquées ni prononcé donc d'abord
exécutons les sanctions donc
réparer le pays on le disait hier nous
étions en train de discuter avec des
jeunes à l'extérieur je disais c'est
bien d'avoir des propositions c'est bien
d'être
très dirigiste c'est bien aussi de
parler gentiment français c'est bien là
c'est bien de parler avec respect aux
français qui est incertain parfois ils
ont un bon programme le bon profil le
bon cv mais il parle pas gentiment aux
gens il respecte pas les gens moi je
veux qu'on soit respecté que tout le
monde soit respecté que tout le monde
soit entendu quel que soit son profil
quelle que soit sa compétence et quelle
que soit sa condition sociale parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a perdu les classes
populaires moi je veux que demain les
classes populaires on puisse répondre à
leurs préoccupations et leurs attentes
aujourd'hui ils sont totalement banni
totalement exclue et partons vous savez
très bien que je dis ce que je pense
certains parfois chez nous disent ça
vous aide pas on s'en occupe pas et ben
moi je vais vous dire je l'avais dit un
grand mère de france j'ai ok il ya des
endroits où ça va être pas mais le jour
[__] ça vole pas tu t'ennuies pas ils
viendront tous mettre le feu à la mairie
là on sera dans l'urgence et on ça sera
trop tard et bah c'était arrivé nous en
sommes là aujourd'hui donc aujourd'hui
font entendre tout le monde fauré
considère tout le monde faut remettre de
l'autorité de la sécurité de la liberté
partout en france et pour ça on a
peut-être des candidats qui sont
meilleurs que d'autres
merci rachida
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci à rachida dati ma question
s'adresse à monsieur charles consignes
merci d'être arrivé merci d'être venu on
est on est très heureux de que vous
soyez avec nous finalement moi je me
suis interrogé hier à 2 heures du matin
quand je suis rentré de la soirée d'hier
je me suis dit dans un pays qui compte
après cinq ans d emmanuel macron une
dette à 116 % du pib une fiscalité qui
reste une des plus élevées d'europe et
du monde des dépenses publiques qui
augmentent plus vite que sous françois
hollande alors que avant son élection
pendant l'élection présidentielle on
nous disait qu emmanuel macron était un
grand réformateur
finalement un candidat libéral sur les
questions économiques alors que
finalement on voit très bien que malgré
la crise qu vide nous avons toujours un
état sûr administré une économie sur
administrer un état toujours plus
présente et mais moins efficace nous les
républicains nous proposons moins d'état
mais mieux d'état nous proposons une
simplification drastique du code du
travail nous avons nous vous proposons
une baisse de la fiscalité diviser par
deux les impôts de production ma
question est la suivante est ce que vous
ne pensez pas que là le véritable la
véritable priorité en france c'est un
tournant libéral sur les questions
économiques est ce que les français
n'ont pas un petit problème avec le
libéralisme est finalement est-ce que
c'est pas les seules solutions qu'on n'a
pas appliqué depuis maintenant 40 ans
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup cher théo michel pour
cette question à peine orienté e
qui est presque une question rhétorique
merci de ton invitation je précise en
préambule je suis là comme personnalité
de la société civile j'ai certaines
affinités avec les idées qui sont
défendues par votre parti je n'en ai pas
pour autant ma carte et s'il ya
certaines choses avec lesquelles je suis
je suis d'accord peut-être que peut-être
que vous faites des rabais pour les
invités
si à certains thèmes avec lesquels je
suis d'accord avec vous il y en a
d'autres avec lesquels je ne suis je ne
suis pas d'accord mais mais je pense
qu'on
on peut se retrouver sur sur l'essentiel
avant de te répondre cher théo je veux
saluer votre présence nombreuse ici
malgré la gueule de bois je crois qui
frappe certains d'entre vous j'ai vu
hier les stories sur instagram
totalement déchaîné qui m'ont rappelé
l'époque du bal à papa ou nadine morano
de manière totalement endiablé elle est
peut-être ici aujourd'hui mettez le feu
au dancefloor
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je trouve ça admirable ça m'a rappelé
et puis vous avez en effet ce jeune qui
l'aiment carayon qui est à l'origine de
mon de mon invitation qui je pense est
un très bon président des jeunes qui met
une énergie formidable de sedan ce
travail qui a ce sourire colgate qui a
été qui a été relevé par le figaro qui
est troublant mais ayez à l'esprit que
trump a le même et donc est presque la
même coiffure d'ailleurs et donc ces
voix là
est en tout cas là même la même énergie
moi je n'ai pas ma carte au républicain
mais j'ai eu jadis ma carte à l'ump
et ça me rappelle de vous voir ici le
meeting des jeunes chère rachida de
nicolas sarkozy oh
oui oui et oui
et je peux vous dire que le meeting des
jeunes de sarkozy au zénith de paris
j'étais même pas en âge de voter j'avais
17 ans j'étais quand même totalement
hystérique dans la salle et nicolas
sarkozy ne pouvait même pas finir ses
phrases tellement il y avait
d'entousiasme dans ce qui dans ce qui
dans ce qu'ils disaient et tellement il
y avait dedans tout est dans la dent là
dans la salle donc moi je trouve ça
admirable que y ait autant de jeunes un
dimanche matin de lendemain de fête dans
cette salle du parc floral pas ce que ça
veut dire que l'engagement politique est
quelque chose qui a un sens pour vous
que vous croyez dans les idées qui sont
défendues par votre parti et surtout que
vous ne pensez pas que la messe est déjà
dite et que l'élection de 2022 et déjà
fait contrairement à ce que répètent des
médias et je tiens quand même un peu à
le dire ici qui sont passés largement
acquis à la cause du candidat sortant
et qui n'ont qu'une envie c'est de
chanter
la réélection triomphale
de ce président qui le soutiennent à
bout de bras qu'il ne critique jamais et
dont il rapporte fidèlement toutes les
actions sans aucune espèce de deux
d'esprit critique la séquence de
marseille ayant quand même été un délire
de communication absolument inouïe c'est
très émouvant de voir manuel macron
découvrir la france à la fin de son
quinquennat mais mais moi ça m'a laissé
songeur et je trouve que les médias là
et avait un rôle de passe-plat qui ne
fait pas honneur à la liberté de la
presse
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vais pas me faire l' arbitre des
élégances je pense comme rachida que
vous avez beaucoup de talent dans votre
famille politique je vois dans la salle
mon ami et avocat francis szpiner qui
est un immense mer du 16e qui est un
immense avocats et dont l'engagement
politique
fait honneur à notre profession
je vois agnès séverin que je connais
depuis haïti un petit moment qui elle
aussi est très engagée sur le terrain
voilà je pense que c'est remarquable
d'avoir des gens comme ça qui se donnent
à la politique puisque même si elle est
très critiquée aujourd'hui la politique
il faut voir que c'est de plus en plus
sacerdotale c'est de plus en plus
sacrificielle je pense d'ailleurs
puisque je vais commencer à répondre à
la question de théo je pense que sur le
plan de la ligne politique que vous
allez choisir moi il ya quelque chose
qui m'interpelle dans le succès j'ai vu
là que vous l'avez applaudi de laurent
wauquiez
c'est que je pense que vous ne devez
faire aucune concession au politiquement
correct je pense que tout le système
vous incite à être tiède à ne pas aller
au bout de ce que vous pensez et je
pense qu'au contraire un programme comme
celui qui était celui de françois fillon
en 2017 c'était un bon programme pour le
pays c'était un programme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était un programme radical mais quand
on a un pays qui décline d'année en
année dans les classements des grandes
puissances il faut un programme radical
c'est un programme très bien construit
c'était un programme très sérieux et
c'était un programme dans lequel vous
n'aviez pas une ligne une phrase qui
constituait la moindre concession à
cette doxa qui va de france inter au
parc national financiers
et donc moi je trouve qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui une pensée pour françois
fillon dont dont la justice vient encore
peut-être pas ce qui arrive son procès
en appel c'est une pure suggestion c'est
peut-être pour faire pression sur les
juges qui vont devoir le juger en appel
la justice vient faire ses fonds de
tiroir et regarder encore et encore tout
ce qu'il a pu faire dans sa carrière et
le persécuter encore et encore alors
qu'elle laisse d'autres gens dans
d'autres situations tout à fait
tranquille à mon avis pourquoi parce
qu'il avait un programme radical qui
déplaisait à cette doxa est donc ce que
je veux vous dire c'est n'ayez pas peur
de déplaire n'ayez pas peur d'être ce
que vous êtes n'ayez pas peur d'être
libéraux n'ayez pas peur de dire qu'il
faut réformer l'état n'ayez pas peur de
dire qu'il faut baisser les dépenses
publiques n'ayez pas peur de critiquer
macro n'ayez pas peur de vous faire mal
voir ça fait un peu jean paul ii ce que
ce que je dis là c'est n'ayez pas peur
mais en politique ça me semble
absolument fondamental surtout quand on
est en ce moment dans une période de
rétrécissement de la liberté
d'expression et où la moindre phrase
tout à coup vaut à son auteur une
polémique incroyable j'en ai eu une la
semaine dernière ce que j'avais eu le
malheur de faire des déclarations sur le
ton humoristique au sujet de mes
habitudes de voyage dans le dans le
train j'ai eu tout un tas de de jaloux
et 2 et 2 et de gens tristes au fond qui
m'ont critiqué abondamment sur les
réseaux sociaux je peux vous dire je
n'en n'ai absolument rien à faire je
m'exprime en me moquant totalement des
critiques je pense que en tant que
jeunes de droite qui est système en
systématiquement stigmatisés parce que
head jeunes de droite c'est faire
l'objet tout de suite de critiques d'un
certain système et ben vous devez vous
aussi vous
[__] complètement des critiques dont
vous pouvez faire l'objet et vous devez
faire votre campagne comme vous
l'entendez y compris avec des casquettes
qui rappelle l'immense président trump
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et donc je réponds en une phrase à la
question de théo michel parce que le
président platret mains de me le demande
le sel question qui était de toute façon
une question rhétorique
évidemment que à mon sens après quand
même quelque chose qui confine à l'achat
de votes toutes ces dépenses publiques
complètement délirante qui ont été
déversés sur le pays au prétexte du coc
vide évidemment qu'il faudra moi je le
dis très calmement ce que je pense au
fond de moi c'est qu'ils font en france
une révolution thatchérienne
ccma scemama ma conviction personnelle
je pense qu'il faut absolument reprendre
le contrôle des dépenses publiques j'ai
vu qu'on se poser la question de
l'utilisation qui est faite de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire etc moi
je dis envoyons un carton de fournitures
scolaires si on le veut aux familles les
plus défavorisées c'est très bien il
faut l'égalité des chances il faut que
tous les enfants de france puisse avoir
les mêmes chances de réussir dans la vie
ce qui est de moins en moins le cas dans
un pays qui devient pays de castes donc
il faut faire ça mais arrêtons de
distribuer de l'argent public qu'on va
bien chercher chez quelqu'un à un moment
donné
[Musique]
comme disait margaret thatcher la
liberté le socialisme s'arrête là où
s'arrête l'argent des autres je crois
assez à cette phrase là
[Applaudissements]
et je pense et je pense très sincèrement
que les classes moyennes et les classes
moyennes supérieures qui sont les vaches
à lait de ce pays qui sont les idiots
que les idiots utiles de ce pays
qui sont systématiquement tondu du début
à la fin alors que c'est des gens qui
travaillent alors que c'est des gens qui
essayent oui d'améliorer leur vie
quotidienne en gagnant un peu plus mais
vous avez immédiatement le rouleau
compresseur de l'état qui vient leur
prendre leur argent pour ensuite faire
les dépenses pharaoniques engagée par le
candidat sortant je termine là mon
intervention ces classes moyennes là ils
en ont marre et vous vous devez être
leur leur candidat donc voilà n'ayez pas
peur de vos de vos convictions et je
laisse la parole
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur blanc une deuxième question
c'est vrai et théo l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure notre pays depuis 2002 détient
le triste record du plus haut niveau de
fiscalité en termes d'impôts de charges
sociales et de normes et finalement
comment revaloriser le travail et
relancer l'ascenseur social en france
merci je ne suis pas avocat je ne suis
pas en politique je suis juste un chef
d'entreprise et et est ce que je
voudrais dire c'est plutôt vous faire un
témoignage je répondrai à votre question
est d'abord remercier christian jacob
que je connais depuis les années 2000 et
salué son esprit assez ouvert puisque
vous le savez peut-être pas mais il a
été l'initiateur de la première loi sur
le commerce équitable en 2005 et on se
rend compte aujourd'hui que c'était un
élément essentiel
d'une politique économique différenciée
qui n'est pas une politique publique
puisque qu'est ce que c'est que le
commerce équitable
c'est un commerce différenciée qui fait
appel à des notions d'équité avec un
prix minimum garanti
pour les agriculteurs avec des primes de
développement pour les pour le collectif
et avec aussi une démocratie à
l'intérieur de petites communautés
qui représente très peu de surfaces
cultivables moins 25 millions de paysans
ont moins de 5 ha ha cultivés donc on
peut pas en vivre et donc toute une
organisation sociale qui a été mis en
place et pour lesquels notre modèle
d'entreprise donc nous avons à peu près
400 salariés nous sommes le leader de ce
marché du commerce équitable et on
travaille beaucoup en collaboration avec
les coopératives et on est c'est
d'essayer de monter un modèle économique
rentable pour les coopératives c'est
toujours aller au-delà de la réflexion
et la réflexion au niveau économique
c'est comment une entreprise comme la
nôtre une pme
est arrivé face aux mastodontes du café
puisque le marché est dominé par quatre
multinationales à acheter quasiment deux
fois le prix du marché et accroître tous
les ans par rapport à un produit tout en
respectant des des agriculteurs
d'implication que l'on doit se poser
toujours c est ce que nous ne devons pas
être les acteurs parce qu'évidemment les
politiques et édicte des lois
souvent actions des tournées on le voit
avec la loi et galim 1 et maintenant la
future et khadim 2 voilà donc on est
dans des problématiques qui sont
différentes entreprises c'est quoi vous
êtes ici 1700 jeunes et moi je trouve
extraordinaire
parce que vous êtes la france de demain
moi qui embauche beaucoup de jeunes dans
mon entreprise je vois que par rapport à
mes 40 ans de deux directions générales
l'état d'esprit a changé on est sur des
esprits beaucoup plus ouvert on veut à
la fois de la bienveillance on peut de
la rigueur on veut un autre mode de vie
en vue du partage donc on veut une
économie qui soit à la fois libéré mais
respectueuse de l'autre et donc je pense
que vous êtes porteur la de cette
nouvelle dimension positive
voilà que nous avons essayé de nous deux
à notre petite échelle d'un carnet dans
lequel la l'activité économique est le
principal moteur puisque une entreprise
même si elle fait du commerce équitable
doit être rentable parce que sinon elle
peut pas créer peut pas monter le
programme ne peut pas se développer elle
peut pas aider les producteurs donc nous
devons tous avoir la référence entre une
rentabilité entre une notion de partage
est une notion de bienveillance et je
pense que vous êtes les les plus à même
de faire cette jonction entre l'humain
qui est vraiment le le devenir notre
société plus personne n'a de repères on
est tous perdu les jeunes sont perdus on
le voit est
segmenté à peu cette réflexion autour
d'un monde complexe souvent nous sommes
tous binet reims et au blanc au noir et
c'est alors que nous sommes dans une
complexité et nomme et en modèle
économique sont très grande complexité
donc effectivement moi ce que j'apprécie
dans vos propositions c'est à la fois la
simplification du modèle économique qui
est indispensable c'est donner de la
liberté mais à la fois une liberté c'est
à la fois une liberté supplémentaire
mais certains font aussi une contrainte
de liberté puisque il faut bien qu'ils
aient des règles pour pouvoir sortir de
cette liberté et donc voilà donc moi ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que nous
devons tous réfléchir en tant que
salarié en tant que chef d'entreprise
entre hank acteurs économiques à comment
modifier le modèle tout en gardant nos
valeurs d'espérance pour une jeunesse
qui n'a aujourd'hui plus de plus
d'espoir donc je pense qu'il faut
redonner cet espoir à tout le monde
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup c'est là le propos
d'expérience si on sait que le parcours
qui était le vôtre monsieur blanc est
absolument remarquable c'est un vrai
honneur de vous recevoir alors on va
peut-être ouvrir le temps des questions
l'idée étant de vous laisser la parole
sur les priorités puisque c'est bien
celui ci on abordera dans la deuxième
table ronde la mise en acte la mise en
musique de ce projet présidentiel donc
sur sur ses priorités qui ont été
identifiés par les républicains vous
avez la parole pour des temps juste un
peu plus court que la moyenne des
interventions de ceux qui viennent de
parler
attendez attendez on va on va apporter
des micros là c'est bon ici
ou sur les micro voilà voilà le v vous
pour voilà
on y va on va en prendre deux et puis on
répondra bonjour à tous vous présenter
s'il vous plaît et puis voilà ça marche
ok alors omar bin saad militants
républicains du 20e arrondissement
merci pour vos propos motivant et
enthousiasmant bonjour incident c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous rencontrer
et d'écouter ce que vous dites est de
suivre ce que vous faites alors j'ai une
question par rapport aux de voir qu'à
chaque citoyen envers la patrie vous
avez dit vous avez parlé de ce que nous
devons au peuple le peuple doit quelque
chose d' importantes à l'état c'est le
vote que pensez vous du fait de rendre
le vote obligatoire pour chaque citoyen
du moins pour les élections
présidentielles merci à vous merci
beaucoup
on va prendre la deuxième question
j'ai deux questions simultanément est ce
qu'il faudrait pas réhabiliter le profit
qui est la minimisation des ressources
pour obtenir le maximum de résultats ce
qui je pense est un but écologique et
deuxième question
non semaine ne s'est pas tout à fait une
question est ce que ce sont pas vraiment
les classes populaires c'est à dire le
tout le monde qui payent le maximum
d'impôt par rapport à sa consommation
c'est à dire que quand on consomme on
paye des impôts et les prix la hausse
des prix la hausse des prix du carburant
c'est tous les impôts que tout le monde
paye et c'est bien entendu ceux qui sont
les plus pauvres qui sont le plus
touchés c'est à dire que la baisse des
impôts c'est pas pour les riches ou les
classes moyennes c'est pas pour les
classes populaires en réalité c'est pour
les plus pauvres et aujourd'hui ceux qui
vont être qu'en plus touchées par
l'inflation grâce à la création
monétaire qui est fait par la banque
centrale européenne ce sont les plus
pauvres dont entendu c'est complètement
le contraire de ce qui est dit
officiellement à l'heure actuelle voilà
merci beaucoup allez on va commencer à
rachida peut-être sur la question qui a
été posée sur le vote obligatoire est ce
que c'est une option à étudier ou pas
comme certains pays d'ailleurs l'ont
fait non mais t'as question est tout à
fait pertinente et on s'en rend compte à
chaque élection moi ce que je déplore
c'est effectivement l'abstention et 7
abstentions
je dois
reconnaître qu'il ya beaucoup d'élus qui
rêvent que de l'abstention moi je pense
que si tout le monde votait beaucoup
seraient aujourd'hui en minorité ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui
élu soit disant avec une majorité sur le
vote obligatoire il ya des pays qui
l'ont fait en europe je crois comme la
belgique ou autre
sur papier c'est bien après moi je pense
qu'il ya une liberté du désir de
participer une liberté d'adhésion sur
sur le vote la mobilisation elle vient
aussi de ce qu'on peut proposer de la
manière dont on travaille donc à la
manière dont on est disponible la
manière dont on est accessible la
manière dont on est disponible et puis
aussi sur la pertinence des propositions
moi je pense qu'en politique
alors j'ai peut-être aussi à rebours de
mais comme dirait charles faut dire ce
qu'on pense moi je pense qu'on peut on
va pas être élu en disant voilà j'ai 100
propositions qui m'aime me suive moi je
pense que les gens se disent il ya deux
trois propositions mais est ce que j'ai
envie est-ce que la cette personne-là
peut sauver la france va faire ce
qu'elle a dit je pense qu'il ya une
incarnation nécessaire et donc pour
susciter l'adhésion il faut s'user faut
avoir une vraie incarnation une vraie
réflexion et de dire moi je vais vous
dire ce que je propose là je vais le
faire pour reprendre une expression
galvaudée quoi qu'il en coûte je ferai
ce que j'ai j'ai proposé et c'est comme
ça qu'on fait adhérer et c'est comme ça
qu'on suscite en tout les cas l'adhésion
vote c'est c'est mon avis sur merci je
suis pas favorable au vote obligatoire
mais c'est intéressant
jean pierre blanc pour les questions
économiques et fiscales en dresseur oui
rapidement effectivement le problème de
l'impôt par rapport aux revenus
est
significatif mais il faut pas oublier
non plus la redistribution donc quand on
regarde le revenu global il faut
regarder l'impôt par rapport à la
redistribution global ce qu'il faut pas
s'empêcher de dire quelle est la notion
du partage de la valeur c'est à dire que
quand on est en disant dans un parti
politique on doit quand même se poser la
question quelles que soient les
répartitions après de dire on est dans
un système où aujourd'hui on se doit de
partager la valeur c'est à dire que les
grands groupes prend des exemples très
précis
quand vous avez un embout demande quand
vous êtes une multinationale en résultat
brut d'exploitation de 15% et sinon vous
êtes patron vous êtes viré donc c'est
facile
c'est clair qu'avec 15 % vous pouvez pas
redistribué de la valeur
au niveau de niveau des des agriculteurs
on est donc il faut qu'ils aient des
textes qui permettent justement cette se
partage et se partagent il est
nécessaire si on veut à la fois un
équilibre social et si on veut aussi que
les jeunes générations et même celles
qui n'ont pas accès à l'essentiel puisse
participer à la vie de la nation donc
c'est cet équilibre qui est qui et de
votre domaine et je pense qu'ils étaient
extrêmement
important à avoir en tête merci beaucoup
on continue avec les questions dans ce
qui en a quelques-unes voilà les mille
que le micro circulent on va en prendre
peut-être trois ans là il y en a des
deux côtés 1 allez-y
bonjour messieurs dames je suis en
deuxième année de sciences politiques à
nanterre je manque d'un collectif sur un
terrain qui s'appelle soyons acteurs et
qui a pour but de redonner envie aux
jeunes s'intéressent à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 et j'ai une
question à vous poser c'est comment
remobiliser cette jeunesse comment la
faire serait intéressé à la
présidentielle alors qu'on voit qu'elle
a vraiment n'a pas été présente dans
l'élection municipale de 2022 ni aux
élections fin 2020 nous les élections
régionales en 2021 merci beaucoup la
question de la mobilisation de la
jeunesse avancez vous venez voilà
jusqu'à
merci soir bonjour excusez moi voilà
j'ai vibré on sait que les horaires
parfois c'est compliqué
j'avais une question sur la kz
rassemblés pour refaire nation parce
qu'on se rende compte de plus en plus
malheureusement quand on assiste à une
archi pays dation c'est que une hausse
du communautarisme et et une séparation
aussi géographique social est ce qu'on
pourrait trouver un juste milieu entre
la simple journée d'appel qui est qui a
lieu depuis maintenant quelques années
et le l'ancien service militaire
quelques ont connu les anciennes
générations qui permettait une mixité
sociale une mixité géographique et qui
faisait qui permet aux jeunes de faire
nation tous ensemble je pense que c'est
une question ok merci
merci on peut prendre une troisième
question
bon voilà peut-être qu'on veut faire
circuler le micro par ici il arrive
bonjour bonjour donc je me présente je
m'appelle collins dégâts donc je suis
dans le comité dlr du zéro cale des
alpes de haute provence donc je voulais
saluer vos interventions tout remercier
théo michel remercier rachida dati pour
son parcours et son combat que j'admire
beaucoup et remercier christian jacob
pour sa présence et et porter une aussi
du coup la voix des jeunes républicains
donc ma question est la suivante on a
parlé du comité du commerce équitable on
a bien vu que les républicains
s'opposent sur les territoires
et pourquoi pas aussi utiliser du coup
cette force pour notre souveraineté
c'est-à-dire
puiser sur le les circuits courts la
production locale pour être on a bien vu
qu'on était dépendant des autres pays
comment comment on peut du coup puisé
cette force dans ce sens merci beaucoup
merci à vous
charles consignes et on pourrait
peut-être aborder les goûts la question
de la mobilisation des jeunes est ce que
c'est une fatalité que les jeunes encore
plus que les autres parfois se
détournent des urnes
moi je pense pas je pense que les jeunes
les votes à l'élection présidentielle
simplement c'est à sète au parti
politique d'aller les chercher je pense
qu'il faut aussi
peut-être prendre plus en considération
leur leurs besoins moi je
me souviens que quand j'étais étudiant
j'étais tout le temps à court d'argent
j'étais tout le temps à me dire que les
jobs que je pouvais faire à côté de mes
études étaient très peu payés peut-être
qu'on pourrait trouver une solution pour
que les jobs des étudiants soient mieux
payés que qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui
je pense que
par exemple les stages pour être bien
davantage payé
je me fais des sites mais je comprends
pas ce qu'on me dit
d'accord d'accord
je trouve que ce que je voulais j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure une question
économique etc en france on a un
problème de
niveau des salaires on a un problème
avec des gens qui sont extrêmement bien
payé tout en haut et des gens une grande
majorité on est dans un système
quasiment féodal de gens mal payés donc
pour faire envie aux jeunes de
s'intéresser à la politique je pense
qu'il faut tout simplement
s'intéresser à l'heure à leur problème
et l'un des premiers problèmes des
jeunes c'est une certaine précarité qui
était un thème assez délaissé par la
droite d'ailleurs qui est plutôt un
thème laisser à la gauche et dont vous
pourriez vous vous emparez après ce qu
il faut faire du tic toc du instagram et
c'est comme le fait le président sortant
j'en sais rien je vous avoue que
moi-même à 32 ans je n'ai pas tik tok je
ne sais pas comment ça fonctionne donc
on est assez vite
ringardisé mais je crois qu'on a ici des
gens qui doivent pour beaucoup maîtriser
ses réseaux je ne pense pas qu'on aura
de problème de mobilisation des jeunes à
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 les
problèmes de mobilisation des jeunes aux
élections on les suit le reste de
l'abstention c'est à dire sur ce qu'on
appelle les élections intermédiaires
mais ça ça peut être aussi assez bon
signe c'est à dire que quand les gens
votent pas c'est aussi le signe que
finalement ils trouvent que les choses
sont pas si mal
si mal géré et voilà tout ce que je peux
dire c'est que j'espère que les jeunes
parisiens vont voter aux prochaines
élections pour qu'il y ait enfin une
alternance à paris ça ça me paraît
quelque chose de très important mais je
pense que c'est un non problème sur la
présidentielle qui arrive je pense que
les jeunes vont voter à l'élection
présidentielle merci théo une réaction
par rapport à cet optimisme de charles
consigny oui évidemment ludovic hamon
ont souhaité réagir sur cette question
de la mobilisation des jeunes évidemment
les les hommes politiques doivent
véritablement intéressé les jeunes
portaient des idées répondre à leurs
convictions concrètes je vais peut-être
faire du politiquement incorrect mais à
un moment donné ça commence aussi un peu
à bien faire la police enfin j'ai
l'impression que certains jeunes leur
seul sujet de préoccupation parfois
c'est leur petite personne parce qu'à un
moment donné les jeunes ils ont un accès
à tous les outils de communication ils
ont facebook instagram twitter tik tok
il n'y a jamais eu autant de publicité
finalement pour les élections donc moi
je voudrais dire une chose aux jeunes
mobilisez-vous parce que il y a des
ancêtres en france qui se sont battus
pour avoir le droit de vote est donc un
moment donné il faut aussi se
responsabiliser
ludovic je te laisse peut-être la parole
pour réagir sur cette abstention des
jeunes
ludovic rachida concertation allait
rachid invasion et sur lisa et peut-être
qu'on peut englober aussi la question de
l'investissement puisque je j'ai à coeur
quand même qu'on réponde aux questions
la question justement de l'engagement
c'est un peu le même l'engagement dans
l'isoloir quand il s'agit de voter
l'engagement aussi au service de la
nation avec ce regret qui courent encore
de ce service national peut-être qu'on
peut en fait la place des jeunes et leur
engagement dans la société bazire at il
alors pourrait rebondir aux propos de
théo moi je veux dire quand je me suis
engagé auprès de nicolas sarkozy d'abord
je suis arrivé à son cabinet ensuite
évidemment je suis venu sa porte parole
ce qui m'avait frappé à l'époque à l'ump
c'était sur les jeunes pop le manque de
diversité pas diversité au sens on
l'entend ou les gens n'osent pas dire
les mots pour la diversité américaines
ou allemandes donc c'était le manque de
diversité sociale les jeunes pop c'était
très même profil il ya plein de jeunes
et j'en ai vu encore hier aujourd'hui et
à chaque fois ou qui m'écrivent qui
veulent s'engager en politique et
notamment moi j'ai toujours considéré
que les étudiants l'université et en
particulier par par ce gouvernement les
étudiants de l'université ce sont les
gilet jaune de l'enseignement supérieur
parce que ce sont les plus maltraitées
ce sont les plus précaires souvent ce
sont ce qu ont pas les moyens de faire
ou des prépa ou des grandes écoles et
moi je vois de nombreux jeunes et y en a
ici qui veulent s'engager mais ils sont
étudiants comme disait charles ils ont
des jobs à côté il voit sa cote est
souvent ils supportent leurs familles
ils aident leurs parents ils ont des
enfants et ils ne peuvent pas avoir un
engagement politique aussi complet aussi
permanents que d'autres jeunes ou
d'autres profils donc ce qu'on a un peu
perdu depuis 2007 je trouve où depuis
2004 et 2007 c'est l'engagement de ces
étudiants populaires qui font l'avenir
de la france qui font la diversité de la
france et donc de pouvoir dans les
universités là vous disais charles a
raison c'est que l'université c'est le
territoire de la gauche ont l'impression
des étudiants mais à gauche comme
l'alternance comme les lycées
professionnels et avec christian on
avait reçu évidemment des représentants
notamment des cfa je pense qu'il faut
investir les cfa les lycées
professionnels les universités et que
vous les jeunes élèves vous puissiez
faire de la place à ces jeunes là qu'au
moins de facilité qui connaissent moins
les codes qui connaissent aussi certes
on leur dit si t'es pas là tout le temps
bah tu seras pas compter et donc les
jeunes élèves vous devez aussi vous même
élargir le spectre vis-à-vis de cette
jeunesse qui n'est pas uniquement des
étudiants de grandes écoles ou deux
dernières années d'université voilà
merci rachida
[Applaudissements]
jean pierre blanc peut-être la question
sur sur les circuits courts oui
justement qu'elle soit extrêmement
importante parce qu'il faut savoir ce
que attend le consommateur aujourd'hui
et notamment les jeunes consommateurs
ils veulent une alimentation plus saine
plus durable plus proche que chez eux ça
repose le problème de l'agriculture que
christian connaît bien et le modèle
économique français que l'on a autour de
grandes coopératives quelquefois un peu
trop un peu trop grande et revenir au
local local c'est à la fois donner les
moyens à une partie de jeunes de se
retrouver dans une agriculture
différencier et aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il ya une forte attente il ya une
demande donc je veux dire c'est vraiment
une voix sur lesquels on a travaillé et
d'ailleurs il faudra peut-être modifier
la loi et galim 2 si elle est votée en
l'état parce qu'elle pose un problème
justement il faut vraiment qu'on libère
cette activité et on a la capacité il ya
de plus en plus de petites coopératives
qui s'engagent dans cette voie c'est à
dire de fabriquer des produits
transformés avec des outils beaucoup
plus petit qui permettent d'accroître de
la valeur au sein de leur organisation
c'est à dire le produit de base qui va
être produits agricoles revendu et il va
y avoir le produit transformé voilà donc
ses terres c'est vraiment une réflexion
à avoir puisque la sakura à la fois le
champ du territoire ça couvre les zones
rurales et sa touche toutes les couches
de population dans un mode de vie qui
est attendu pour rejoindre un peu ce que
vous dites pourquoi ils vont pas voter
pour ces c est ce qu ils se retrouvent
dans tout ce qu'on leur propose
finalement qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'ils veulent eux par rapport à leur
propre mode de vie que l'on peut
critiquer un tick tock etc mais qu'est
ce qu'ils attendent eux de la société et
peut-être sait pas que nous nous
attendions à l'époque donc posons-nous
un peu la question voilà merci beaucoup
juste on va reprendre une dernière série
de questions pour pas éluder tout de
même la question sur la question la
question sur le service national je
pense qu'on a on s'est penché sur cette
problématique là on est bien conscient
que pour
la suppression du service national qui
se justifiait complètement au moment où
elle a été décidée par jacques chirac a
aussi engendré un certain nombre de
problèmes donc la solution que les
républicains porte dans cette campagne
présidentielle c'est une solution
intermédiaire qui remet toute une
génération en capacité sur quelques mois
de rendre un service à la nation je
pense qu'on a on a vraiment été quand on
a travaillé sur les motifs les moyens de
restaurer la cohésion nationale c'est
quelque chose qu'on a vraiment eu en
tête et finalement cette solution
intermédiaire c'est plus intense et plus
10 mois ces quatre mois mais c'est aussi
un engagement fort qui pour le coup est
proposé à l'universalité des jeunes
jeunes filles comme jeune homme et à ce
titre là je pense qu on arrive ici même
si on sait que ça coûte un peu d'argent
à être finalement à être conforme à cet
idéal national que nous défendons la
nation ne se décrète pas elle se forge
elle se forge à l'école elle se forge
aussi par un service qu'on rend à ses
concitoyens voilà un petit peu pour
répondre à votre question sur la
position d'équilibré qu'on a trouvé à
les dernières séries de questions et de
réponses vous avez la parole
moi ma question s'adresse du coup plus à
un madame dati par rapport à la justice
en parlais tout à l'heure de l'effectif
et l'effectivité des peines
on a beau mettre en place plein de
solutions plus de place en prison les
peines plancher qui ont été honteusement
supprimés par ministre de la justice de
françois hollande mais est ce que le
vrai problème c'est pas ce qu'ils
prononcer les peines c'est à dire les
juges et les magistrats parce qu'on a
beau par exemple faire plus de place
dans les prisons les peines plancher si
derrière les juges et les magistrats il
n'applique pas les peines comment on
fait parce quand je vois que quelqu'un
qui habite à levallois qui détend de
l'argent faute fiscal prend 10 ans et
qu'un violeur ans prend 5 j'ai honte de
ma justice quand on viole et comprend
cinq ans de prison en moyenne c'est une
honte doit y avoir effectivement une
hiérarchie dans les peines mais comment
est ce qu'on fait pour ses juges pour le
syndicat de la magistrature dont on sait
qu'il est énormément orienté comment
fait-on pour ces personnes là qui
prononce en réalité les peines même si
on a les moyens derrière et que eux ils
font pas les îles font pas le job on
peut pas s'en sortir du coup comment on
fait merci rachida va répondre mais je
on va prendre les deux autres questions
vous avez la parole
bonjour
alessia lisent une l'on prie je vous en
prie ouais tu es heureux un représentant
des français de l'étranger je suis élu
comme conseiller des français et
étrangers et président du conseil
consulaires du paraguay donc je viens de
loin et j'ai d'ailleurs un candidat pour
les jeunes républicains
j'attends les réponses puisque j'ai
trouvé j'ai mis du temps mais j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un de bien qui pourrait
bien représenter j'aurais fait ce 25 ans
et est architecte parfait voilà j'ai une
question sur la francophonie
j'ai une question sur la francophonie et
le développement extérieur de la france
et l' influence de la france comme vous
avez traité de la question je suis
étonné qu'ils aient aucun vraiment
documents importants sur des français de
l'étranger et partisans les jeunes qui
sont délaissés dans deuxième ou
troisième génération qui n'ont pas les
moyens d'aller à l'école française et il
est baisse des crédits de la sociale de
leurs voeux et ça c'est très important
puisque c'est notre culture deuxième
chose il faudrait aussi mettre de
l'ordre dans l'état
quant à l'ambassadeur lève le drapeau de
la france 14 juillet et qui fait un
discours uniquement en langue étrangère
sans parler france sans parler une un
seul mot français je trouve ça très
mauvais que des contrats des consuls
honoraires sont ne sont pas français et
ne parlent pas le français pour la
france c'est très mauvais donc l'image
d'une langue française y compris dans
les alliances françaises le semaine de
la francophonie que j'assiste et
ça c'est des films étrangers étaient
sous titré en espagnol et peuvent et
parents français et ça ne parlait pas
français je trouve ça scandaleux
alors il faudrait mettre de l'ordre
aussi dans la diplomatie française et
dans la fpt la fédération des français
étrangères sivos où j'ai dit merci
beaucoup on va passer de ce côté là tout
au fond là soit là
on va prendre encore deux autres et ce
sera tout bonjour merci
j'avais clément jay de la fédération du
doubs et donc moi je voulais plutôt axé
ma question par rapport à lac se
protéger donc moi je suis soignants je
suis infirmier et
donc la question c'est est
faut-il un peu soutenir enfin soutenir
l'hôpital est aussi son système de santé
et aussi soutenir les soignants puis les
aider à pouvoir répondre à la population
merci beaucoup
allez on va commencer la question de la
justice rachida c'est la question était
directement posée on comprend bien
pourquoi la question la justice moi je
suis pas devenu magistrat par hasard
pour des tas de raisons lorsque j'ai
vécu dans des endroits où l'injustice
régnait souvent et donc c'est avec
conviction que je me suis engagé dans la
magistrature aujourd'hui je suis
toujours statutairement à magistrat et
je ne quitterai pas ce statut pour des
tas de raisons et d'ailleurs encouragé
par simone veil je suis devenu magistrat
d'ailleurs j'ai sa robe de magistrat
quand j'exerce parce que non seulement
la justice et le pilier de l'état de
droit mais ça permet aussi de préserver
la démocratie dans laquelle nous vivons
aujourd'hui la justice où on peut
réformer les quantum de peine or ajouté
des listes délit tout ce que vous voulez
mais on a la première réforme qui est à
faire les dents le fonctionnement ce que
nous on a commencé à faire lorsque
nicolas sarkozy était président que
j'étais garde des sceaux on la réforme
et le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature
on y introduit la notion de
responsabilité parce que c'était
extrêmement important et nous avons
d'ailleurs modifié à l'époque les
instances et notamment l'instance
disciplinaire et nous avons mis en
oeuvre la possibilité de recourir direct
au conseil supérieur de la magistrature
pour le justiciable en cas de
difficultés qu'un magistrat au par
exemple regarder est il normal que dans
l'affairé outreau le juge soit encore en
fonctions quelque part dans d'autres
fonctions la personne la personne aurait
été révoqué donc aujourd'hui c'est de
rétablir ce qui a déjà ce qui ce cas
françois hollande totalement abroger
toutes ces réformes là il les a mises à
terre et moi je pense que l'augmentation
de la judiciarisation de la société à
outrance est compris dans la vie
politique y compris pour les chefs
d'entreprise c'est parce qu'on a eu une
faiblesse du politique plus l'eau
politique s'affaiblit plus la justice
prend le pas et moi je ne me résous pas
être dans une société où effectivement
que les rapports sociaux que les
rapports économiques que l'organisation
de la société se fasse sous main de
justice ensuite le seul que la question
soulevée tout à l'heure monsieur sur
l'application des sanctions
l'effectivité des sanctions d'abord il
faut avoir une politique pénale moi je
n'ai pas entendu une seule fois depuis
2010 est un garde des deux sauts et non
c'est une politique pénale connaissez
vous la politique pénale de lutte contre
les trafics de drogue moi je la connais
pas connaissez-vous la la politique
pénale concernant les violences urbaines
je ne la connais pas et donc il n'y a
pas de politique pénale aujourd'hui sur
tout ce qui gangrène et minent la
société - garde des sceaux y compris sur
ce qui s'est passé à marseille moi j'ai
été assez troublé par l'absence de
parole du garde des sceaux après les
événements qui sont intervenus notamment
à marseille donc d'abord il faut avoir
une politique pénale claire et assumée
ce que nous faisions quand il y avait
des volumes sur ben on donnait des
instructions claires notamment au
parquet le sur les violences conjugales
nous avons été le gouvernement et ça
pour un débat que j'ai eus notamment
avec nokia pas elle ne peut pas
évidemment le contredire nous avons été
le gouvernement qui a le plus fait pour
la lutte déco contre les violences
conjugales et d'ailleurs aurélien pradié
a bien fait de rappeler récemment que
toutes les mesures qui sont aujourd'hui
mises en oeuvre c'est grâce aux textes
que tu as porté devant l'assemblée on ne
doit pas ça à ce gouvernement
donc
sur la justice on a les idées claires on
a des programmes clairs et sur
l'effectivité de la peine évidemment
quand des sanctions sont prononcées
qu'elles sont pas exécutées ça pose un
problème et c'est vrai que on a eu un
débat et charles va me contredire parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas d'accord je
considère que quand on a une politique
pénale forte et que des mesures
notamment de détention sont prononcés à
l'audience il faut également prononcé le
mandat de dépôt qui va avec sert de dire
à quelqu'un vous êtes condamné à cinq
ans de prison et on vous re convoquera
et en gros qu'on voit que jamais c'est
sûr que ça crée de l'impunité ça génère
l'impunité et on le voit aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ils savent très bien que les
peines seront pas prononcés et encore
moins à exécuter et donc moi je dis que
la vertu de la sanction la répression
c'est évidemment la certitude de la
sanction mais la certitude de la
sanction c'est aussi extrêmement
dissuasif sur les constructions de
places de prison juste avant que je
vienne ce matin j'avais une réunion avec
certains magistrats parce que
effectivement je leur demande sur on en
train de réfléchir sur comment lutte
contre les trafics internationaux de
stupéfiants et on est arrivé sur les
sujets de la prison j'ouvre ce sujet je
parle sous le contrôle et l'autorité de
christian jacob il me disait que par
exemple les prisons c'est vrai que ça
peut être très cher et pour cause parce
que à part la droite personne n'a jamais
eu de plan de construction de prisons
les places qui sont construites
aujourd'hui date de notre gouvernement à
sadac peuple ça date pas de hollande et
encore moins des mails macron donc
toutes les places de construction qui
sont construites aujourd'hui datent de
nos annonces et non à des mesures que
nous avions prises aujourd'hui toutes
les prisons sont construites de la même
manière et coûte très cher et il
faudrait qu'on puisse avoir des prisons
différenciées en fonction de certaines
catégories notamment de détenus et ça
irait plus vite notamment sur les escort
qui pose un problème il ya par exemple
des détenus pour lesquels les scores de
l'ours ne serait moins nécessaire nous
avions beaucoup d'ailleurs à l'époque
c'est nous qui avions multiplier par
cinq le nombre de bracelets
électroniques puissent et on en
bénéficie encore aujourd'hui le bracelet
anti rapprochement et d'ailleurs
aurélien a beaucoup fait pour pour cela
avec damien wood mais sur par exemple
les centre de semi-liberté les centres
éducatifs fermés les prisons pour
mineurs parce que ce qu'il faut savoir
les quartiers plume pour mineurs que
nous avions commencé à fermer parce que
moi je n'y suis pas favorable
il n'y a pas d'obligation de formation
ni d'activité pouvait dormir toute la
journée dans votre cellule vous bagarrer
avec le personnel pénitentiaire sans
problème les établissements pour mineurs
il ya un vrai projet qui va avec
obligation de formation scolarité
activités réinsertion et ont conduit
vers la réinsertion les mineurs qui sont
aujourd'hui incarcérés et d'ailleurs
taubira a arrêté ses projets et tout ça
est parti évidemment en vrille après
après leur départ et donc sur la
politique pénale sur la justice en
général il faudra revoir le conseil
super la magistrature il faudra revoir
l'organisation évidemment de la justice
moi par exemple je trouve qu'aujourd'hui
on filme les auditions des mineurs dans
les cabinets d'instruction notamment
souvent le fait pas parce qu'on fait un
pv de carence on dit le matériel ne
fonctionne pas et ça n'est pas
enregistrée moi je serais assez
favorable complice filmer les auditions
les interrogatoires les confrontations
dans les cabinets des juges
d'instruction parce que les magistrats
veulent de la transparence pour tout le
monde sauf pour eux et donc moi
j'aimerais bien que la transparence soit
aussi applicable aux magistrats
merci rachida
jean pierre blanc la question de la
place du français dans le monde vous
avez une vision assez panoramique sur
sur ces questions oui tout à fait parce
que je voyage beaucoup donc plusieurs
fois par an
d'amérique centrale en afrique on n'a
été aussi ensemble et en asie et là où
on est étonné c'est la france a une
image extraordinaire à l'étranger qui
n'est pas en rapport avec
l'investissement qu'elle fait puisque
les budgets que ce soit pour les
alliances françaises pour la pour la
diffusion la langue française ou pour la
culture c'est à dire ça passe par les
deux phases c1
effectivement comme le disait monsieur
promouvoir la culture française à
l'étranger
et d'autre part l'éducation de la langue
française dans les années aux françaises
pour vous donner juste un petit exemple
sur la plus grande alliance française
qui se trouve à santiago de cuba qui
doit former plusieurs milliers de
cubains parents à la langue française le
budget annuel qui étaient à louer
c'était 50000 euros pour
payer je ne sais pas combien de
professeurs avoir une école hainaut donc
c'est à dire qu'il faut vraiment
repenser la place de la france à
l'étranger par le biais des ambassades
et par le biais d'un rooney lmnp
aujourd'hui deux nouveaux ambassadeurs
aussi qu'ils sont beaucoup plus actifs
mais il y en a un certain nombre qui ne
sont pas porteurs de cette image là et
je rejoins tout à fait monsieur donc il
ya vraiment un gros travail à faire là
dessus merci beaucoup et on va finir
avec schalk ont signé une question a été
posée sur finalement la considération
que le pays doit à son système de santé
on sait qu'il est en première ligne
depuis le printemps dernier que le
problème est majeure même en dehors de
la crise épidémique est ce
qu'aujourd'hui la france traite assez
bien son système de santé merci d'abord
je voulais je dois quand même très
brièvement je vous rassure répondre à la
calamine très brièvement je vous rassure
répondre à madame le garde des sceaux
rachida dati sur la question des
politiques pénales et c'est parce que je
suis avocat pénaliste j'ai une activité
qui fait que je suis toutes les semaines
dans l'est devant les juridictions
répressives et dans les cabinets des
juges d'instruction et dans les prisons
j'étais hier matin même à la santé
je peux vous dire que quand vous mettez
le pied dans une prison alors même que
vous savez que vous allez en sortir une
heure après
quand même la seule chose que vous avez
envie de faire c'est d'en partir le plus
vite possible et donc moi ce que je vois
c'est que contrairement à ce qu'on pense
les juges sont peut-être de gauche
peut-être moi je crois qu'ils sont
surtout corporatiste que surtout ils ne
rentrent jamais de comptes à personne
qu'on ne peut pas engager leur
responsabilité
et qu'il se
couvre les uns les autres mais
ce que je constate c'est qu'ils ne sont
pas du tout laxisme dans la sanction
c'est faux de croire ça les juges sont
durs dans la sanction je ne vous
souhaite pas de vous retrouver devant un
tribunal correctionnel
devant une cour d'assises devant un juge
d'instruction devant un juge des
libertés et de la détention je ne vous
le souhaite pas les juges y mette du
ferme y mette du mandat de dépôt vous
sortez avec des menottes et vous n'avez
plus que vos yeux pour pleurer le
problème qui se passe c'est que à mon
sens c'est pour ça que la droite prend
parfois ce problème de la mauvaise
manière le problème il n'est pas celui
des sanctions le problème il est celui
du volume de la délinquance et de la
criminalité que la machine judiciaire et
policière française a à traiter c'est à
dire qu'il ya une telle explosion des
trafics des violences et de tous faits
de délinquance et criminalité que les
juges n'ont tout simplement pas les
moyens techniques de les traiter et
c'est pour ça qu'on peut avoir ce
sentiment qu'il y a une une impunité
mais en réalité quand les gens sont pris
dans les mailles des d'edu du filet ils
sont très sévèrement condamnés moi je
vais vous dire en un mot vous ne pourrez
pas faire ce pays sans les banlieues
sans les jeunes de banlieue puisque
c'est là-bas que malgré tout l'essentiel
des trafics de drogue etc est à déplorer
vous ne ferez pas la guerre hop en lieux
vous ne ferez pas la guerre à vos
concitoyens qui viennent de ses
quartiers au contraire vous devriez vous
les jeunes républicains allez les voir
aller les chercher travailler avec eux
il ya énormément de talent dans ces
quartiers il s'exprime dans la musique
il sait grimm dans l'autre sens
l'entrepreneuriat il s'exprime dans les
médias il ya énormément de jeunes qui
ont faim et je me souviens d'ailleurs
chère rachida pour en revenir à lui
pardon mais sarkozy il y allait dans ces
quartiers alors certes il parlait du
karcher de la tolérance zéro mais il
tendait la main à ces jeunes et il leur
disait si vous travaillez vous aurez les
internats d'excellence
on vous tendra la main on vous prendra
avec nous et donc la france elle se fait
avec les banlieues elle se fait avec ces
jeunes là et plus vous les laisserez sur
le côté j'entends et moore qui veut
envoyer l'armée etc mais c'est n'importe
quoi plus vous les laisserez sur le côté
plus vous aurez de la délinquance et la
criminalité et vous pourrez mettre tout
ce que vous voulez de peines plancher de
sanctions automatiques même
d'incarcération sans procès pendant
qu'on y est l'incarcération sur décision
du procureur pourquoi pas je suis sûr
qu'il y en a à droite nommé d'accord
mais vous pourrez faire ça vous n'y
arriverez pas prenez les avec vous et
des et d'ailleurs
l'enquêté conclura voilà je ponds plus
le
truc qui marche bien c'est les centres
éducatifs fermés mais bref ouvrez zan
plutôt que des prisons parce qu'il ya
des digues et des éducateurs parce que
de nouveaux on considère ces jeunes et
là on les sort de leur criminalité sur
la question de l'hôpital c'est vrai que
on a hypothéqué tu mens je trouve même
si évidemment on était sincère applaudi
les soignants pendant le le confinement
où on devait faire un petit papier pour
aller chercher une baguette de pain ce
qui à mon avis quand même restera
évidemment que ce qui était criant c'est
le manque d'argent public de moyens pour
l'hôpital et moi ce que je trouve que
vous devriez proposés si vous proposez
une ligne libérale c'est de dire on a
besoin des services publics essentiels
on a besoin de la police on a besoin de
l'hôpital on a besoin de l'armée on a
besoin de l'école on n'a pas forcément
besoin dé concert solidaire financé sur
fonds publics de la mairie de paris on
n'a pas forcément besoin
de tout de toutes les initiatives
diverses et variées de marlène schiappa
sur des thèmes complètement lunaire on
n'a pas besoin de financer
des tas d'associations
pour le genre etc il ya un moment donné
l'état c'est quand même ça veut dire
quelque chose l'état français c'est une
machine qui est efficace l'hôpital il a
été absolument remarquable ces derniers
mois en france il faut voir ça le
dévouement de ces soignants qui sont
payés une misère penser aux salaires des
infirmier de nuit qui sont payés à peine
le smic
est bas proposé dans votre projet de
recentrer les dépenses publiques sur les
services publics et fonds essentiels et
là encore n'ayez pas peur d'y aller avec
des coupes très clair dans toutes les
dépenses publiques
fantaisiste que tous les autres
candidats n'hésitent pas à engager
merci beaucoup charles consigny merci
jean pierre blanc merci rachida dati bon
ce moment punch y coller sur la place à
la deuxième plénière c'est à dire
l'application de ce beau projet lorsque
nous aurons gagné les élections merci à
vous